this video is sponsored by Skillshare
use the link in the description to watch
my course or thousands of others with a
free two-month trial in 2018 the u.s.
imported 540 billion dollars worth of
goods from China but exported only 120
in response President Trump imposed
tariffs immediately shaking the Chinese
American and therefore world economies
but while the trade war defines today's
economy another deficit will decide
tomorrow's in the 2017-18 school year
three hundred and sixty three thousand
Chinese students came to study in the US
while only 24 thousand Americans went to
China this on the surface isn't all that
surprising
what's weird really weird is how fast it
happened all of a sudden starting in
2007 Chinese students in the US
absolutely exploded accounting for 93
percent of all international student
growth in the last decade more students
come from China to America than the next
six countries combined including India
despite having almost the same size
population so why so many why so sudden
and is the u.s. right to worry about
incoming spies the answer has less to do
with academics and more with economics
complex social dynamics and above all
politics on June 7th Chinese cities
become eerily quiet traffic is as busy
as ever but no horns are honking stress
is collectively unusually high free
water bottles are handed out and drones
watch overhead today tomorrow and
sometimes on a third day 10 million
students across China take the national
higher education entrance exam aka the
GAO Cao aka the most important nine
hours of a Chinese person's life the
test covers Chinese language and
literature math foreign language usually
English and the choice of social or
natural science the top roughly seven
million scores are admitted to college
and a select few are offered places in
the c9 mainland China's equivalent
the Ivy League but unlike the SAT AP or
IB kaukau scores are really the only
factor in Chinese college admissions the
first 18 years of your life therefore
are dedicated to preparation leading up
to the big test parents for an incense
pray and book hotels near the exam to
avoid traffic students sometimes study
with IV drips some known as gal cow
migrants travel to other provinces with
higher admissions quotas in hopes of
having a slight advantage when the day
finally comes provincial governments
order quiet streets for concentration
and fly drones to catch cheaters
supporters of the Gow cow say it levels
the playing field creating a meritocracy
wherein any student from any Geographic
or socioeconomic part of China has the
same opportunity for social mobility
critics in turn argue a level playing
field is only ever an illusion that
success is handed to those with families
wealthy enough to afford private tutors
like continued middle-class growth the
National exam is both a practical and
political tool for maintaining stability
shifting questions of who has power and
who is entitled to riches on to the
individual the extreme sometimes
insurmountable stress they say doesn't
even produce good citizens or employees
while Chinese students rank very highly
in math and science they're often seen
as lacking in other skills like creative
and critical thinking a side effect of
their rigid education system classrooms
are dominated by the teacher who
lectures behind a podium to a sea of
totally silent students expected to
memorize as much as possible to ask
questions is both to disrespect your
teacher and admit to your peers that you
don't understand the material
finally discipline is placed above all
else with low performers at one high
school not being allowed air
conditioning for any number of these
reasons some disenchanted parents seek a
way out if their child performs poorly
on his or her high school entrance exam
rather than lose face families may place
them in international schools designed
to prepare them for exams like the SAT
instead others pursue an education
abroad with the intent of eventually
migrating the whole family
or simply for more opportunity the
perception is that while school in China
is more intense
up until the cow cow afterwards students
feel they've satisfied their family's
expectations and can relax at university
whereas American college is when
students start getting serious
in other words students leave China on
their parents suggestion who usually pay
their tuition and pay do they there are
English lessons extracurriculars for
admissions exam fees and travel costs on
top of that families pay agencies about
ten thousand dollars per child for help
in the process in other words this is
only possible thanks to China's rising
newly wealthy middle class and the
demographics which leave parents with
only one child to pay for and more
importantly only one chance to get it
right
the truly wealthy get started even
earlier sending their child to an elite
American feeder middle school which can
charge up to sixty seventy thousand
dollars a year and when old-fashioned
studying doesn't work upper-class
families resort to gifts usually about
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and as much as six point five million
there's one more unexpected reason
Chinese students come to America when
dong Xiao ping began opening up the
country in the 80s and 90s creating
thousands of newly rich families he also
for the first time allowed students to
study overseas for this reason the first
international students who returned to
China or its most well-off launching
high-paying high-profile careers this
association of studying in America and
success in life has never faded so while
the American Dream may not be alive and
well in America it certainly is in
Beijing Americans have Louis Vuitton
McMansions and Porsches Chinese people
have Harvard and Yale one hospital in
central China even named its maternity
wards after Ivy League schools for good
luck all of these factors help explain
this but they don't justify this why did
it all happen so fast
to answer that we need to understand how
schools really make money broadly
speaking in the u.s. there are two
University business models the first way
a school can make money is simple
charging students private schools are
the apple of education
forgo massive market share in exchange
for a smaller number of higher paying
students and because they attract high
income families they can expect good
lifelong customers aka
endowments on the other hand the way
public schools pay the bills is a little
less obvious lower tuition is made up
for by state and federal funding aka
everyone's favorite taxes government
subsidizing is great when it's great low
prices grant low-income families access
to a great education the problem is that
state and federal governments have other
priorities and are subject to economic
downturns during the 2008 recession
Americans spent and made less money
governments collected less revenue and
colleges received less funding from 2008
to 13 states alone lost out on two
hundred and eighty three billion dollars
now ten years later most of us have long
forgotten about the recession but not
universities still in 2018 state funding
for higher education was down thirteen
percent from before the crisis so as
government subsidies fell schools
immediately turn to a new subsidy
international tuition the current model
is one where colleges can segment prices
without appearing to discriminate in
other words tuition is set very high but
aid is handed out very generously the
average full-time undergraduate in
2017-18 received nearly fifteen thousand
dollars in total aid but while something
like 85% of students received some
amount of financial aid international
students almost always pay full price at
Michigan State University for example
in-state freshmen pay twenty five
thousand sixty four dollars a year for
tuition fees room and board
out-of-state residents pay just over
double and international students pay
nine thousand one hundred and thirty
three dollars on top of that across
America an international student
generates about twice as much revenue as
an in-state resident students also
complain about a so-called international
tax where schools place a greater
emphasis on English courses to prolong
their studies increasingly Chinese
students find themselves caught between
two worlds
as more and more students return home
30% in 2007 but 80% today they're often
disappointed by what they find while
English is still very valuable and many
find high-paying jobs in America the
rest hike we as they're known in Chinese
have a disadvantage one study found us
diploma holders were 18% less likely to
receive a call back from potential
employers than Chinese ones on the other
hand they may also feel isolated and
unwelcome in America because schools
tend only to keep one or two dorms open
during breaks during which international
students tend to stay on campus they get
placed in the same dorms have less
opportunity to perfect their language
skills at a harder time socializing
outside their bubble at the same time
some Chinese students are experiencing
delayed or rejected visas and
accusations of espionage the fear stems
from Confucius Institutes or Chinese and
student and scholar associations groups
set up by or associated with China's
Communist Party on American campuses
officially their goal is to help Chinese
students acclimate abroad like by
organizing parties around Chinese New
Year Chinese embassies also create
WeChat groups to organize students even
paying them to welcome Xi Jinping during
his 2015 visit to Washington several
Chinese students and faculty have been
arrested or fired in recent years for
alleged spying or failing to disclose
connections to China according to
sources president Trump seriously
considered banning all Chinese students
completely only narrowly deciding
against it after an ambassador pointed
out how it would harm American schools
students and STEM fields in other words
most Chinese students are already
subject to additional scrutiny
the truth is visa issues are not yet
widespread and the US government has at
times even encouraged Chinese arrivals
with trump declaring quote we want to
have Chinese students go to our great
schools and great universities they are
great students and tremendous assets
regardless issues are common enough to
create a perception of risk leading to
an 8% drop of international students in
2018 who increasingly choose other
countries like Canada or affordable
Thailand
the University of Illinois went so far
as to take out a four hundred and twenty
four thousand dollar insurance policy in
case of a significant drop and Chinese
students the US can and should be
worried about Chinese influence on
campuses their free open minded approach
has the potentially dangerous side
effect of also creating a vulnerable
hole easily filled by nationalist
propaganda there has never been a better
time in history to be wary of China's
influence abroad but there has also
never been a more important moment to be
cautious about conflating a government
and its ideology with 1.4 billion
individuals suspecting everyone of
espionage leaves America economically
and culturally weaker not stronger every
year Chinese students contribute 15
billion dollars to the US economy
education is now Australia's third
largest export more than tourism and
behind only iron and coal but whether
economically useful or not cultural
exchanges act as a countervailing force
to propaganda both exposing Chinese
nationals to a wider intellectual world
and American citizens to foreign
cultures the fact that America has so
many high ranking sought after
institutions where even Xi Jinping sends
his daughter is a massive diplomatic
advantage that risks being wasted if
foreigners aren't welcome when students
return to China these schools often
constitute their entire conception of
America the one that spreads to friends
family and eventually decision makers
cutting off Chinese students may help
win today's trade war but welcoming them
is the only way to stop tomorrow's
conflicts before they even begin while
not everyone can leave their country and
study abroad we all have access to some
of the most interesting classes online
with Skillshare for example maybe after
watching the magic of in and out you
want to start your own business this
course can help you create an amazing
logo for it perhaps you want to avoid a
marketing disaster like hallway in which
case you should watch these brand
strategy courses from the experts
whatever you want to learn like business
design or investing skill share has
thousands of classes to teach you you
can try skill share today with the two
month free trial using the link in the
after that an annual subscription is
less than ten bucks a month
thanks to skill share and to you for
watching